[Music]
thanks for your interest in learning
about artificial intelligence
stanford online offers several programs
to suit your needs
this video will help explain some of the
key differences between our offerings
the first is the artificial intelligence
graduate certificate
a series of graduate courses that
provide the foundation and advanced
skills in the principles and
technologies that underlie
ai including logic knowledge
representation
probabilistic models and machine
learning
students take graduate courses in the
same quarter they are delivered on
campus at stanford
and can pursue topics in depth with
courses available in areas such as
robotics
vision and natural language processing
graduate courses award letter grades and
students earn stanford credit the second
is the artificial intelligence
professional program a series of
professional courses adapted from the
graduate level equivalents
classes in the professional program
contain all of the topics from the
graduate course they are derived from
but add flexibility by dividing material
into core content versus optional
material
provide additional structure to support
coding assignment completion
and are offered multiple times per year
professional courses are graded pass
fail
and award continuing education units
ceus
courses in both programs provide
opportunities to get support
and meet other learners in graduate
courses the majority of peers are
current students at stanford
an office hour support is provided by
faculty and stanford graduate student
course assistants
in the professional courses the
participant community is made up
primarily of working professionals from
around the world
and office hours are conducted by course
facilitators who have thrived in the
graduate equivalent course at stanford
or demonstrated significant industry
experience in the field
you can also view lecture content from
both programs for free on youtube
we look forward to welcoming you to our
artificial intelligence student
community
for more information visit us at
[Music]
online.stanford.edu